شكراً لك على المقدمة الرائعة. مرحباً
، أنا عالم آثار مصري أحفر من أجل
لقمة العيش وهذا ما أفعله بشكل أساسي ، لكني
أريد فقط أن أسأل الجميع عن شيء
ما يتبادر إلى الذهن عندما أقول
علم الآثار أو مصر ربما تفكر
في كنز الذهب إنديانا جونز أو حتى
روس من الأصدقاء في الواقع أحصل على
الكثير على الرغم من أنه عالم حفريات ولكن
لدينا نفس الفرشاة في الواقع لذلك نحن
متشابهون بطريقة ما ولكن ما
أفعله في الواقع هو أنني أعمل هنا هذه هي الدلتا
ومصر ، لذا فهذه كلها مواقع قديمة
حيث الناس  اعتدت أن أعيش في العالم القديم ،
لذا أركز هنا في الدلتا ، لماذا
لأن هذا في الواقع لن يكون موجودًا في
الأربعين عامًا القادمة ، ولهذا السبب من المهم حقًا
بالنسبة لنا العمل هنا ، وأتتبع
مواقع الاستيطان والدلتا ، وهذا
ما أجريته في بحث الدكتوراه.  تدور حول لأنني
أهتم بأشخاص مثلي
ولماذا يفعلون أين يعيشون ماذا
يؤمنون بمن يعبدون لذلك
هذا ما أركز عليه الآن ، فكيف
حدث كل هذا يسألني الجميع
لماذا  هل دخلت حتى في علم الآثار ،
إنها ليست وظيفة مكتبية عادية حقًا ، من
الواضح أنه كان يجب أن ألتحق
بالطب الهندسي مثل العديد من الأشخاص في
هذه الغرفة ، لكن هذا عندما بدأ كل شيء ،
كنت في الواقع في التاسعة من عمري في
المدرسة والصف الثالث
حصلنا على  فيديو إعادة تمثيل
هوارد كارتر ، الأب الروحي لعلم
المصريات ، كان يكتشف قبر الملك توت ،
لذا فهذه هي المرة الأولى التي رأيت فيها
أي شيء له علاقة بعلم
الآثار وكان مجرد اكتشافهم
للمقبرة التي كان يدخل الغرفة
لأول مرة على الإطلاق.  من خلال ثقب صغير
يختلس النظر من خلاله بشمعة صغيرة
وسأله أحد العمال
عما تراه وهذه هي
المرة الأولى التي يرى فيها أي شيء في الغرفة
وكل ما قاله كان أشياء رائعة منذ
تلك اللحظة تم بيعي في التاسعة
عامًا ، يمكنني أن أخبرك بصراحة أنني كنت أعرف
بالضبط ما أردت أن أفعله في حياتي ،
لكن لم يكن لدي أي فكرة عن كيفية القيام بذلك ، لكنه ظل
عالقًا معي
، وانتهى بي الأمر بفعلته ، وأصبحت عالم
آثار سريعًا من أجل  وارد حتى الآن ،
هذا ما أفعله في الواقع ، هذا ما
أبدو عليه في الميدان ليس تمامًا مثل
لارا كروفت ، الزي
مختلف نوعًا ما لا يمكنني ارتدائه حقًا
في المناطق التي أعمل فيها ولكني أفكر في
نفسي مثل  هي في رأسي
على أي حال ، هذا هو المكان الذي أعمل فيه ، لقد كنت
محظوظًا بما يكفي للعمل في بعض
المواقع غير العادية من طاقم Elle
و tombos والسودان حيث ركزت على
مقابر الدولة الحديثة وحتى الأهرامات
موقعين في الدلتا مثل Royal City
of  العلم بالإضافة إلى
مجمعات المعابد وأخبر تاماي ، لذا فإن القدرة حقًا
على أن تكون أول شخص يحمل
قطعة من التاريخ في يدك
وأنت أول من يحمل
شيئًا مدفونًا لمدة 3000 عام زائد هو
حقًا شعور لا يوصف و  على
مر السنين ، بدأت في الحصول على
تخصص وهذا أحدها يسمى
المسح الجيوفيزيائي ،
لذا فهو في الأساس عبارة عن أشعة سينية عملاقة على
الأرض هنا أقوم بإعادة معايرة
مقياس المغناطيسية بالجهاز الذي نستخدمه
لأشعة سينية على الأرض وأنا  أنا قادر على رؤية
ث  كان نوعًا من الهياكل على وشك
التنقيب لأننا لا نحفر بشكل أعمى
لأن ذلك سيأخذنا إلى الأبد ، لذا
فأنا قادر على معرفة ما إذا كان هيكلًا محليًا
إذا كان عبارة عن قاعدة هرمية أو
مجمع معبد حتى نحصل على
الفكرة وهكذا  تعلمون يا رفاق أن هناك ثلاثة
رجال يمسكون بهذا السلم وليس
لأنني كنت ثقيلًا جدًا على السلم ، فقد
كان ذلك في الواقع لأن السلم كان ممسكًا
بمسمار واحد ، لذا فهو عمل خطير
أيضًا ولكن حسنًا ، يبدو الأمر كما لو أنني
أعرف ماذا  أردت أن أفعل ذلك في التاسعة
من عمري ، وحققت ذلك بشكل صحيح ،
لم يكن الطريق إلى هذه النقطة
سهلاً تمامًا كما توقعت
، اعتقدت أنني فعلت كل شيء بشكل صحيح ،
حسنًا ، دعنا نرجع سريعًا عندما كنت في التاسعة من
عمري  كنت أعرف ما أريد القيام به بشكل
صحيح ولكن لم أكن أعرف كيف
واصلت للتو دراستي ، لقد
حصلت على درجة البكالوريوس في علم الآثار وهذا
ما يفترض أن أفعله ، ثم حصلت على
الماجستير لأنني كنت أتفوق
فيه حقًا.  فعلت الماجستير في علم
الآثار واستمر  افعل ذلك في
جامعة دورهام ثم ماذا أفعل الآن
قررت أن الوقت قد حان للعودة إلى
بلدي وسأعود إلى مصر
وسأدرس علم الآثار المصري ،
ما هو أفضل مكان للعمل
فيه أكثر من مصر  كخطأ بسيط في
ذلك ،
هناك بعض العقبات التي لم أكن
أتوقعها على الإطلاق ، لذا بعد أن
عدت إلى الوراء متحمسًا للغاية ولأكون
صادقًا معكم يا رفاق عندما عدت
من أساتذتي ، اعتقدت في الواقع أنني
سأصبح وزيرًا لـ  الآثار في
ذلك الوقت ولم يكن ذلك دقيقًا للغاية ،
كنت ساذجًا بعض الشيء في ذلك
العمر ، لذا عدت إلى الوراء ، حيث كنت أريد أن أفعل
كل شيء في العالم ، كما تعلم ، كنت
أرغب في تغيير كل شيء ، ثم
تعرضت للكثير من
البيروقراطية  لقد كنت نوعا ما في فقاعة قبل
ذلك لم أكن أعرف أن هناك الكثير من
البيروقراطية والمقاومة في مصر على
وجه الخصوص ولكن في الواقع في معظم البلدان
وخاصة في هذا المجال ، لذلك
تلقيت الكثير من ردود الفعل العكسية لما كنت
أفعله  كان يواصل رسالتي للحصول على درجة الدكتوراه
الكثير من الأعذار التي أعنيها أنني لم أكن
أتوقع أنني كنت فتاة
ولا ينبغي أن أفعل ذلك أو ربما
يجب أن أدرس الدكتوراه في الخارج
سيكون أفضل بكثير أو أنني كنت
صغيرة جدًا وغير مؤهل أو  أنني
يجب أن أتزوج وأن أنجب أطفالًا ،
ما هو الهدف من التعليم على أي حال
حتى يتم إخبارك بالكثير من الأشياء ، لذلك
قررت من خلال كل هذا التقدم
إلى مجموعة من الأشياء فقط لإبقائي
مستمراً أثناء قيامي بدراسة الدكتوراه  لذلك
تقدمت بطلب للحصول على ستة أشياء مختلفة لمنح
زمالات تدريبية سمها ما شئت
وبالنسبة للأكاديميين في الغرفة ، فأنت تعرف
المدة التي يستغرقها تنفيذ هذه
التطبيقات ، إنها عملية شاقة
تستغرق إلى الأبد لديك لتبرير
نفسك والعديد من مشاريع مبرر المقالات
تحصل على رسائل  من التوصية
مهما كان الأمر يستغرق أسابيع وربما شهورًا
حتى أقوم بذلك ، فعلى أي حال ، قمت بعمل
ستة طلبات كاملة لدي ستة طلبات كاملة
والآن كانت فترة
الانتظار التي أنتظرها للحصول على النتائج
التي مرت أسبوعين من اليوم الأول.
لقد تلقيت بريدًا إلكترونيًا على الخط الأول في هاتفي
ونأسف لإبلاغك بلاه بلاه بلاه
بعد ذلك مجرد طمس لم
أعد أتذكره بعد الآن ، لقد تم رفضي من
أول خط لي ، لقد كان تدريبًا داخليًا
قلت إنه بخير بصراحة إنه
مؤلم  قليلًا لكنني كنت على ما
يرام ، لم يتبق لدي
شيء أخسره
بعد ذلك ، جاء في رفض آخر ، والرفض
التالي والتالي ، لذلك في هذه
المرحلة لدي خمس حالات رفض
جميعها تبدأ مع نأسف لذلك  أبلغكم بذلك
في كل بريد إلكتروني حتى الآن ، لقد اعتدت للتو
على عدم وجود صفقة كبيرة على حق خمس حالات
رفض ، لقد كانت ضربة كبيرة لغرورتي ،
لقد أصبت بالدمار التام ، لقد
عدت متحمسًا لتغيير IV ثم
اعتقدت أنني لم أفعل  الحصول على أي شيء كيف يمكن
أن يحدث ذلك ، ما الذي ارتكبته بشكل خاطئ ،
ثم بعد بضعة أشهر ، استغرق الأمر
تسعة أشهر من اليوم الذي تقدمت فيه بطلب للحصول
على تطبيق vi وكان هذا الطلب
هو طلب الوصول الخاص بي كلما
تقدمت بطلب للحصول على أي شيء أعتقد
أنه يجب عليك دائمًا  دائما تصل إلى شيء ما
هذا خارج نطاق دوريتك ،
فقط تقدم بطلب للحصول عليه بغض النظر عن سبب المتعة فقط ،
لذا فإن آخر مرة لم
أفهمها حقًا لم أكن أعتقد أنني
سأحصل عليها ، لذا أتذكر هذا اليوم جيدًا ،
لقد كانت الساعة 11:15 مساءً.  في
مكتب والدي في المنزل ، تلقيت بريدًا إلكترونيًا على
هاتفي ، وهذا هو البريد الإلكتروني الذي يعجبني ، ها
نحن نعيد مرة أخرى ، إنه رفض آخر ، اسمح
لي بأخذها ، ثم في السطر الأول
لم يقل أننا نأسف لإبلاغه
لقد قلت يا آنسة شوي العزيزة ، نريد فقط
أن ننصحك بأن
جمعية ناشيونال جيوغرافيك قد منحتك هذه
المنحة للمشروع المقترح
وبهذه الطريقة حصلت عليها حقًا حصلت على
منصب أحلامي ، وكان هذا هو
التطبيق السادس الذي أحلم به بصراحة  لم أفكر أبدًا في
أنني سأتطرق أبدًا أو
حتى أنهم كانوا سيفكرون بي ، وكان
من المنطقي فجأة أنني
أدركت سبب رفضي من الخمسة الأوائل
وما كان يجب أن أكون محطمة للغاية
لأن هذا هو ما كان يعنيه بالنسبة لي
على المدى الطويل حتى ناشيونال جيوغرافيك ما
يفعل  هذا يعني أنني حصلت على منحة
لتوجيه الحفر الخاص بي أخيرًا طوال هذا الوقت ، لقد
كنت جزءًا من فرق أخرى
ومهام أخرى وهذه هي الطريقة التي تتقدم بها ولكن
لتتمكن من الحصول على تمويل ، هذا هو
أصعب جزء بالنسبة لعلماء الآثار
لديك حقًا  لإثبات سبب أهمية هذا الموقع
ولماذا أنت مؤهل
بدرجة كافية لرئاسته ، لذا فإن
هذا هو
أكبر شيء يمكن أن يحدث لي على الإطلاق وكعالم
آثار على مر
السنين
القدرة على الذهاب إلى معسكرات التدريب في
السويد والعاصمة والتعرف على أروع
العلماء والمستكشفين والمغامرين
في العالم والحصول على National
Geographic كمنصة ، هو
الشيء الأكثر روعة
الذي يدعمونه للغاية في
كل العمل الذي أقوم به  وقد أعطاني حقًا
دفعة للأنا ، أعني أنه ليس جغرافيًا ، فمن
لا يعتقد أن هذا جنون ،
لذلك تعتقد بالنسبة لنا أنني نجحت في القيام بذلك منذ أن كنت في
التاسعة من عمري ، لقد فعلت ما أريده الآن
وفعلته ناشيونال جيوغرافيك
يجب أن تحصل على إذن لأنك
لديك تصريح تحتاج إلى الحصول عليه
قبل إجراء التنقيب هنا ، لذلك كنت
بحاجة إلى التقدم للحصول على مجموعة من
التصاريح واعتقدت أنها صفقة
منتهية التمويل من ناشيونال جيوغرافيك
وهذا أمر شرعي إلى حد كبير ولم أتعرض
لرد فعل عنيف كثيرًا بسبب  كما تعلمون جميعًا يا رفاق ،
لدينا الكثير من المشكلات المتعلقة
بالحصول على أذونات في أي مجال
ولدينا الكثير من المقاومة ، لذلك
تم إخباري كثيرًا بأنني كنت أصغر من
أن أفعل ذلك لتوجيه عملية الحفر الخاصة بي
أحيانًا أيضًا  لقد قيل لي
إنني لست مؤهلاً بما فيه الكفاية وأن المفضل لدي
كان في الواقع من شخص في منصب رفيع
أخبرني أنه سألني أنه
مثل كيف أعرف أن National
Geographic شرعية بدرجة كافية لدرجة
أنني لم أكن أعرف حقًا كيف  أجب
بصراحة ، ربما ستكتشف ذلك الآن ، لذا
فهذا هو موقع الحفر الذي
تلقيت المنحة للعمل عليه ، هذا
طفلي على اليسار عبارة عن صورة
قمر صناعي من قمر صناعي للتجسس من السبعينيات ، هذه
هي الطريقة التي يستخدمها الموقع  تستخدم لتبدو تلك
البقع التي تشبه الأسنان أ  فيما يتعلق بالذيلين ،
فإنهما عبارة عن تلال مرتفعة ، وعلى اليمين
هذا ما هو عليه اليوم ،
يتم تغطية التل الجنوبي بالكامل ، لذلك هذا في
دلتا ما ذكرته سابقًا تم
تجاوزه تمامًا من قبل القرى الحديثة
وهذا هو سبب وجود ضرورة ملحة للعمل
لذا  شمال تل هو المكان الذي أريد أن
أعمل فيه ، لذا على أي حال قصة
طويلة بعد عام من القتال مع
الجميع ، ومع كل مؤسسة للحصول على هذا
التصريح ،
حصلت عليه أخيرًا بعد اثني عشر شهرًا ،
وأنا قادر على توجيه عمليات التنقيب الخاصة بي ، لذا
فهي مجرد إهدار  الكثير من الوقت في
النوم ولكنك قادر على القيام بذلك في
النهاية والشهر القادم ، سأذهب بالفعل
إلى هذا الموقع وأبحث هناك ، لذا فإن
ما أريد أن أقوله
بشكل خاص للجيل الأصغر
سيكون ثابتًا إذا كان هناك شيء ما  أنت
حقًا تريد حقًا أن تمارس القوة الكاملة
بغض النظر عن أي شيء وعندما يخبرك الناس
بعدم جدوى ذلك ، فإنها ستدفعك بالفعل إلى
الرفض وستشكلك
وتدفعك وتجعلك تنمو من أجل هذه الأشياء
وتصبح مرنًا  عندما يستمر الناس في
الحصول على أشياء ضدك ، فإن ذلك
يجعلك أكثر صرامة ، وتكتسب جلدًا سميكًا
بمرور الوقت في البداية ، نعم ، هذا مؤلم ،
لكن الرفض التالي يكون
أقل قليلاً ، أما الرفض التالي فهو أقل قليلاً
تعتاد عليه وهو في الواقع  يساعدك ،
إنه أمر جيد ، واستمر في التركيز
على أهدافك فقط ، وأنا أؤكد على أهدافك
فقط تجاهل الضغوط الاجتماعية ، فأنت
لست مضطرًا للانتباه إليها عندما
يقول لك الناس لا أو لا يمكنك فعل
ذلك ، فأنا الأول  لفعل ذلك وعندما
يقول الناس إنه لم يتم القيام به ، فهذه أكثر
جملتي المكروهة في العالم
تجعلها تحدث حقًا ، يمكنك أن تكون أول من يفعل
ذلك ، إنها في الحقيقة ليست مشكلة
وتثق في العملية بغض النظر عن ما
يحدث في مكانها الصحيح
أعني في معظم الأوقات من التجربة
عندما تبدو حياتك وكأنها تنهار
إلى أجزاء ، فهي في الواقع تقع في
مكانها وأردت فقط أن أقول إنه
بعد كل هذا مررت بالكثير
من العقبات وهناك الكثير في
المستقبل.  بالتأكيد لكنك جنرال الكتريك  من
خلالهم وفي نهاية اليوم أقف
هنا على هذه المنصة
كعالم آثار وكمستكشف ناشيونال جيوغرافيك
وعلى الرغم من كل الصعاب بغض
النظر عن كل من أخبرني أنني لا أستطيع فعل
ذلك ، فأنا أضمن لك عودة
دائما أقوى من النكسة شكرا
لك
[تصفيق]